hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and in this video
I will be talking about Saitama from one
punch man and why he is the perfect hero
for our so called useless generation if
you happen to be someone who was born
between the 1980s and the early 2000s
you've probably been referred to as a
millennial at one point or another and
let's face it the media and society at
large haven't been too kind to the
millennial generation Millennials have
been accused of being the most useless
generation the worst generation and
we've also been accused of being lazy
carefree spoiled and generally confused
about life
we've been blamed for thinking only
about ourselves and our own enjoyment
while neglecting the well-being of
society as a whole and because our
generation largely hasn't had to deal
with cataclysmic events like the two
world wars the Vietnam War and the Cold
War we are accused of being incapable or
unwilling to deal with the challenges of
life now obviously these accusations are
gross generalizations that cannot
possibly represent every member of the
Millennial Generation
but this is a narrative that continues
to persist in the media the iconic
superheroes that we all know like Batman
and Superman or spider-man and Iron Man
were created during very different
historical periods such as the period
between the two world wars or during the
civil rights movement of the 1960s and
the Cold War and of course the heroes
that I mentioned were shaped by these
tumultuous times but to the Millennials
even need a superhero of their own if we
all have it so good if we're not facing
any real challenges and if we are
spoiled and entitled is a true
Millennial hero even possible after all
what problems could this Millennial
superhero solve for a generation that
apparently has no real problems enter
Saitama from one punch man when we first
meet Saitama he is basically a neat and
a hero for fun and his appearance an
entire life are extremely me mobile back
when he was an unemployed man in his
early 20s and after being rejected from
yet another job interview
Saitama begins to feel that nothing
matters
more when he comes face-to-face with
krob want a a giant crab like monster
Saitama refuses to run away the monster
is surprised by this but he decides to
spare Saitama because his lifeless eyes
remind him of his own and it is at this
point that the lifeless and aimless
Saitama decides to pursue his old
childhood dream which is becoming a
superhero for fun this idea of becoming
a hero for fun is exactly what people
who criticize Millennials associate them
with instead of working regular jobs and
being productive members of society
Millennials just want to have fun and
pursue silly childhood dreams and what
could be more of a silly childhood
fantasy than the idea of becoming a
superhero however in the crazy world a
one-punch man
Saitama develops a training routine that
over the course of three years turns him
into an incredibly overpowered hero with
greater physical strength than anyone
else in the world even though his
training routine consists of doing a
hundred push-ups a hundred sit-ups and a
hundred squats every day along with a
10k run so nothing outside the realm of
possibility Saitama somehow becomes so
strong that he can defeat virtually any
opponent with just one punch whether
it's an overpowered villain a gigantic
monster or a ninja assassin Saitama can
defeat all of them in one punch now this
is of course outlandish to imagine in
our own world and one punch man is a
comedy that in many ways parodies more
traditional shown in anime and manga one
punch man asks what would happen if
instead of following a hero as he slowly
gets stronger we follow a hero was
already the strongest to such an extent
that his life has become boring mundane
and unsatisfying instead of spending
vast amounts of time training and
fighting villains Saitama defeats most
villains within seconds and he spends
his time reading manga playing video
games or looking for a good deal at the
supermarket in many ways Saitama
represents everything that critics of
Millennials accuse us of being a bunch
of apathetic and bored nerds who lack
purpose and guidance in their lives but
there is one major difference Saitama
just happens to be the strongest
creature on the planet and presumably in
the entire universe but despite the fact
that Saitama is so strong and
fact because of it he still experiences
the same lack of purpose and meaning in
his life that Millennials often
experience even the strongest opponents
pose no challenge to Saitama whatsoever
he defeats every threat with shocking
ease and this has left Saitama deeply
bored unsatisfied and indifferent he
experiences an existential crisis and
loses the ability to feel basic human
emotions in the same way as other people
when you are never in any real danger
when you never have anything to be
afraid of and when literally nothing
poses any sort of challenge to you you
eventually lose the ability to feel the
thrill of overcoming a difficult
challenge the excitement of solving a
difficult problem and the adrenaline
that comes with facing adversity and
triumphing over uncertainty I would
argue that facing difficult challenges
and overcoming them is absolutely
necessary for us to develop as
individuals and for Humanity to progress
as a whole if we really lived in a
Garden of Eden like the one from the
Bible where all of our needs were always
met and we never had anything to worry
about we would be so bored and
unmotivated because we already have
everything we could possibly want so we
would never have anything to aspire to
we would also have nothing to fear so we
would never experience the satisfaction
that comes with facing our fears and
overcoming them and if we live this way
for many generations it is possible that
even our minds would stagnate to the
point that we would become little more
than zoo animals and that is a pretty
scary thought
and this is why Saitama is such a
perfect commentary on the negative
portrayals of Millennials in the modern
world
at first glance Saitama has no real
problems because he is so incredibly
strong that no one could possibly
challenge him and yet ironically this
very fact becomes his greatest problem
as he no longer has a clear meaning or
purpose in his life and we could say
that a similar conundrum is currently
facing Millennials the popular
portrayals of Millennials are of course
blatant generalizations and not all
Millennials have had it easy by any
means
for instance I was born in a country
that no longer exists because it was
torn apart by Civil War and I still
remember the war and being a refugee
because of it that is just one example
but it is important to mention that just
because there has been no major conflict
since World War two in say North America
that clearly doesn't mean that there
hasn't been major conflicts that
Millennials
other parts of the world have been faced
with and of course other parts of the
world have also faced other challenges
like poverty but even if we take the
North American millennial as the example
here it isn't true that these people
haven't been facing any challenges since
the 1980s modern technology has
developed an unprecedented rate and the
children and young people growing up
during this time have faced challenges
that their predecessors could not have
even imagined the advent of things like
the internet and smartphones provides
many new opportunities for this
generation but it also poses new
challenges challenges for preserving our
privacy challenges for maintaining
meaningful human relationships and
challenges for managing the connection
or the lack thereof between the real
world and the virtual world not to
mention that the economic changes that
have occurred in the West in the past
few decades have had a staggering impact
on the lives of Millennials the large
factories that in the past would employ
members of a family for multiple
generations have disappeared as
manufacturing jobs have migrated from
developed nations into developing
nations
unlike the boomer generation before them
Millennials by and large cannot expect
to get a job right out of school and
keep that same job until they retire
that means the Millennials cannot tie
their whole identity in with their
employment and they cannot always search
for meaning or purpose in life directly
through their career this adds to the
feeling of confusion and indifference
toward society at large and one thing I
love about sytem eyes how beautifully he
represents this millennial predicament
right down to his animation which is
often deliberately drawn in a strikingly
simple and Meany style to reflect his
general indifference and aimlessness in
life
nevertheless when Saitama gets serious
are passionate for some reason his
animation changes and becomes sharper
emphasizing that while Millennials may
be portrayed as aimless confused and
indifferent they do have passion and a
strong sense of right and wrong that can
still emerge under the right
circumstances funnily enough I think
that saitama's millennial heroism and
the true nature of his character is
perfectly represented in a single bonus
chapter of the manga chapter 34.5 which
bears the simple title salmon in this
chapter Saitama is sitting on the roof
of a building and quietly enjoying his
lunch of rice vegetables and salmon as
he is eating a middle-aged man climbs up
on the ledge of the roof
saying that he just got laid off and his
wife and kids left him and he is going
to jump and end at all when he notices
saitama the man tells them not to try to
talk to him and not to try to stop him
and at first sight of my act as if he
has no intention of doing anything he is
just trying to eat his food and peace on
the street below a C class hero called
red nose is trying to play the hero and
convince the man not to jump but it is
immediately clear that red nose is
primarily interested in getting positive
media attention for himself the man on
the roof says that heroes like red nose
could never get through to him they
could never understand his plight
because all they have to do is say a few
words and then they bathe in the praise
of everyone the man says outright that
this isn't real work channeling the
older generations lament about the fact
that they feel they had to work harder
than the Millennials but never received
the appreciation that they deserve as
all this is happening Saitama merely
continues to eat his lunch and the man
goes on talking about his plight how he
hates people who just do whatever they
please while he sweats blood working for
his family and his company as the crowd
on the streets gets restless and some of
the onlookers even tell the man to hurry
up and jump because they're busy and
have other things to do Saitama simply
says to the man I can't stop you and I
can't fix your problems
you're free to jump if you want the man
asks are all heroes like this he says to
site them off you don't have any
real-world experience to use in
dissuading me be free huh only the young
can do that again this reflects the
belief of the older generations that
they had to work hard all their lives
while the Millennials act carefree and
do whatever they want the man begins to
say something along the lines of someday
you'll know what I mean a classic line
older generations like to give the young
but right in that moment
Saitama drops his salmon the salmon
falls from the building in Saitama
rushes off to retrieve it running along
the facade of the building at incredible
speed and arriving at the bottom before
the salmon then grabbing it with his
chopsticks before it can fall Saitama
then just rushes back up the roof of the
building using his incredible physical
ability to jump up instantly the man on
the roof looks on in utter shock as
Saitama merely says whew that was close
I saved it up for last I wouldn't want
to drop it the man is so shocked by
saitama's incredible power which seemed
to come out of nowhere that he
accidentally steps off the edge but
Saitama instantly jumps up and saves him
dropping his salmon along the way the
man thanks Saitama and on his way down
he thinks to himself that he didn't have
the courage to jump anyway the man
wonders if he did all that just for
attention if he just wanted someone to
listen to him someone to help him before
he left Saitama told him do what you
want next time you want to jump do it
where I'm eating
we then see a shot of Saitama salmon in
pieces on the ground the man thinks that
Hiro was too good for me as he exits the
building and the people outside take
pictures and videos of him with their
cell phones and some even expressed
disappointment that he didn't jump after
all this fuss as the man walks away from
the crowd thinking about the concept of
just living life the way he wants and
Saitama goes off to fight a monster we
are left with a lot to think about all
that stuff Saitama said at first about
not having an interest in stopping the
man from jumping because he was more
interested in his salmon wasn't true at
all as soon as the man was in genuine
danger
Saitama dropped the salmon without
thinking twice in order to save him this
speaks to the fact that although he
likes to mess around and act like a bit
of a troll at times like so many of us
Millennials saitama's heart is in the
right place he has the heart of a hero
and he will always do the right thing
when it comes down to it also the life
of a traditional salaryman is a
difficult one especially in Japan where
the work hours are extremely long and
the social pressures to fit in and do
well are extremely strong it's easy to
see why this salary man who just lost
everything would feel that he has
nothing to live for and why he would
look down with a version on these young
heroes who receive all this praise just
for walking around in eccentric costumes
this perspective is very similar to how
the older generations look down on
Millennials in our own world they see
Millennials as not working as hard as
they did but the Millennials seem to
need constant praise and adoration
through social media and that's not to
say that social media culture and
celebrity culture don't have serious
problems and one punch man recognizes
that they do the onlookers in this
chapter who seem to actually want to see
the man jump just so they could film it
and probably post it on social media
were representative of a serious problem
and the fact that Saitama is often
accused of being a fraud because people
can't understand that he can be as
strong as he is when he isn't ranked as
high as he should be according to the
hero
Association standards speaks to the fact
that we assigned too much value to
ratings and popularity in our society
including on social media and people are
often misunderstood and even outright
slandered on social media based on
minimal information despite the fact
that Saitama deals with extreme boredom
and lack of purpose because he never
faces any real challenges despite the
fact that he deals with false
accusations and slander and despite the
fact that he starts out as just a hero
for fun Saitama is a true hero whose
heart is in the right place and who
always does the right thing when it
comes down to it as a millennial he
faces unique problems that the older
generation do not fully understand and
they are issues that we can all relate
to what do we do with our lives what is
our purpose how do we cope with the
constant scrutiny gossip and sometimes
outright lies that we all face both in
real life and online like Saitama we
will likely deal with many of these
things through humor through memes
through anime manga and videogames and
by undertaking our own hero's journey in
order to find out how we can leave a
meaningful life and help make the world
a better place the idea that we can
actually relate to someone who is as
ridiculously overpowered as Saitama is
pretty outlandish and yet one the
creator of one punch man succeeds in
making Saitama a relatable sympathetic
and fundamentally modern superhero the
perfect superhero for our so called
useless generation let me know what you
guys think down in the comments is
Saitama the hero we need is he the hero
we deserve is he the hero in all of us
and what do you think about his
character in general I'd love to hear
from you if you want to see more one
punch man content on anime uproar you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and one punch that
notification bell a huge thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work and when I
especially thank our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
keelon and chubs is the man and also are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clients including ace 17
FF
beep Maddy Mac James Ahmad and a lowland
Adam if you guys feel that our content
provides value for you and you want to
support more be sure to check out our
patreon link in the description even
donating a single dollar will give you
access to our anime uproar patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching I really appreciate
it and until next time see us space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]